a warning from metro police tonight
don't leave your garage door open it
could be the perfect way for thieves to
get in and take your belongings madison
kimbrough went to the northwest valley
this evening to talk to neighbors
joining us now live with the details
madison
metro police is reminding everyone to
keep their garage door closed just like
this as several people across the valley
are keeping it open for hours at a time
causing concern for a lot of northwest
valley residents
we've just seen a lot of thefts people
catching people getting into their
garages leaving stuff on their doorstep
and people taking it madison lugrace
lives in this northwest valley
neighborhood and she along with other
neighbors say the amount of burglaries
taking place nearby is startling metro
just put out a warning to valley
residents specifically in the northwest
to keep your garage doors closed as
thieves are walking in and grabbing as
much as they can take seems like a lot
of things are happening now you know
just not good situations
people either
getting their house broken into or
garage stuff police and security
consultant tommy byrne says leaving your
garage door open is one thing but these
thieves can get in even when your garage
door is closed so lock your car as well
in and out
in a minute or less
it's whatever they can grab disable the
garage door opener
you know unplug it or turn it off
uh depending on
how you have access you can do either
one put a padlock when you're when the
garage door is down so that the garage
can't even be manually open in addition
maintaining good lighting around your
home and having security cameras is
always a good deterrent
and if you were wondering what some of
the top items stolen are we have tools
and athletic equipment they are at the
top of the list reporting live madison
kimbrough live local now